I can see Punam has joined from India uh
and uh I couldn't make out the name but
uh Pakistan uh and
uh again like we have forgotten folks
from Pakistan Ghana heart has joined
from
Nigeria and gopal has joined from
Bangalore so keep the introductions
coming in we'll be starting right on
time in a few minutes meanwhile uh we
can just uh do a a quick round of
introductions before we start it's
always good to know right folks who are
joining especially this webinar so this
is a global webinar so you'll see folks
uh joining from uh different different
parts of the world so uh do give us your
introductions on chat here and we'll
start the session uh right in few
minutes uh so uh no no no folks only
speaker will have the access to some
folks uh I'll just quickly take you
through the ground rules here before we
start and and uh meanwhile folks who
have just joined uh I'm rashak Khan I'm
your host for today's webinar and I'm
joining from all the way from India
Bangalore and uh we are just doing a
quick round of introductions here and uh
introducing ourselves on chat here
before we
start awesome please do let us know your
name as well along with where you're
joining us from because sometimes it's
very hard to make out your name so uh
off from the email ID uh email IDs you
have uh so before we start uh please
keep the introductions coming in I'll
just quickly take you through the ground
rules
here of the session so as we move on uh
so there are few easy ground rules you
need to basically follow and know things
about so if you have a question um for
our speaker Mark here today who has
already joined us you can put on your
questions in the Q&A box uh the session
is recorded in case you want to go
through the recording of the session
again or if you have missed anything you
can expect a follow up email with
recording link webinar certificate and
bonus offer for attending this webinar
now what exactly is this bonus offer so
bonus offer is for the program the P
University's post Cas program digal
marketing which will be covering in this
session we'll be talking more about that
but we'll talk we'll be talking about
top things to do uh in 2024 for digital
marketing career uh before that so and
uh as we move on uh basically for the
webinar certificate part here now you
need to stay till the end of the session
for the webinar certificate
uh also uh to request a proof of
attendance for this webinar you need to
provide us your full name in the post
webinar survey so why the full name
because as you can see sometimes it's
hard for us to make out your exact name
from your email ID so the full name will
actually help us personalize your
webinar certificate with your uh name
which you would want to see there so
please do that now what exactly is the
post webinar survey post webinar survey
basically is a popup Zoom popup when I
end the session which is of 60 Minutes
duration you will get a zoom popup
immediately uh if you have joined fore
mobile or your laptop desktop and uh
it's a very quick survey form and you
can put on your full name there so I
hope that makes it clear and uh I still
see a lot of introductions coming in on
so that's great uh folks please uh do
give us your introductions on chat this
is a global webinar so we're just
networking a bit and doing a quick round
of introductions before we start and uh
today's webinar is powered by simply
Lear world's number one only boot camp
uh we are very proud that we have been
the digital space
uh for almost uh last 13 years and uh we
have transformed lives by empowering
people we are multiple skills covering
uh categories of courses from AI machine
learning data science business analytics
cyber security uh cloud computing uh
product management and digital marketing
and many more today we'll be talking
about digital marketing uh in this
webinar and we have advanced over five
lakh plus careers in over 150 plus
countries and we have 800 plus qualified
trainers uh to work with and uh let's
quickly go through the agenda of today's
session uh so we'll be talking about
digital marketing careers in 2024 top
things to do before you begin and uh
what this program offers now what
program the puru University's uh
postgraduate program in digital
marketing and how this program gets your
job ready uh and enrollment steps of the
program and a special duration for the
Q&A part so the Q&A part uh as you can
see the chat is basically popping up
with a lot of introductions that is how
active the chat is
and uh if you have any questions for our
speaker uh Mark today related anything
related to digital marketing in general
uh you can basically ask that question
in the Q&A box now where is the Q&A box
so Q&A box is in the chart box where we
having a lot of interesting uh
conversations here and uh basically you
can navigate it just beside the chat box
uh it will be by the name Q&A and you
can put down your questions there any
queries you have so I'll make sure that
we address all of your queries by end of
the session we'll try to take as many
questions as possible during the session
but in case in case we're not able to
answer your query please don't worry
please stay till the end uh we we'll be
taking that during the Q&A part of the
session so uh I hope that makes sense
and uh please know uh links personal
links on the chat here uh I see that
folks are
sharing links on the chat here uh please
do not share personal links on the chat
here
just one second give me one second and I
see uh folks uh still giving
introductions so we have started on
time so uh we're just uh waiting to get
started let me uh
quickly go through the chat here once
and seeing your wonderful introductions
on chat here so that's
great uh for folks who have just joined
right now we just quickly went through
the ground rules here and also the
agenda of the session and uh we'll start
with uh getting to know you a little
better here uh and for that uh we would
love to know a little bit about you
starting with how many years of
experience do you currently have as you
can see a poll just got launched where
you can see four quick options there
where uh you can just vote for the most
suitable answer uh now when I talk about
experience here I I'm talking about work
experience so how many years of work
experience do you currently have and uh
you can see four quick options here I'll
just R those options for you and the
first one less than two years second one
2 to 5 years third one 6 to 10 years and
uh the last one more than 10 years so I
as I was speaking uh first of all the
chart box is completely blowing up and
also the poll is also getting a lot of
responses from you most of you folks
have already voted for the V so that's
great we have gotten a very set of
active audience here so uh once again
welcome everyone it's fantastic to have
you all on board we are just getting
started with the session and I'm loving
the introductions we are getting on chat
let me just quickly read out a few of
the introductions on the chat here I can
see unti has joined from Canada I can
see Balaji has joined from Tamil Nadu W
up from
Bangalore and uh I see tapti has asked
as that are you going to share the
recording in the past webinars I was
informed that the recording will be
shared
so yeah you will be seeing the recording
over your mail you should check your
mail uh please do let us let me know you
can just DM me here in case you're not
able to find a mail uh from Simply learn
webinars uh email ID and please do let
me know if you're not able to access
them I'll help you out don't worry and
uh I think I'll just give five seconds
for the poll here uh before we
start okay I think folks are still
voting for this
poll
okay fine I think most of the folks have
already shared the responses for the
poll so I think I just give 5 Seconds
more and in this poll quickly so 5 4 3 2
1 let me quickly end the poll and also
share the results with you
folks as we can see that uh I'm sharing
the results with you folks of when we
have asked how many years of experience
do you currently have so we can see 52%
of the folks have less than to years of
experience
and 19% of the folks have two to five
years of experience and also 19% of the
folks have more than five years of
experience and 10% of the folks have six
to 10 years of experience so thank you
so much for sharing that with us really
appreciate it really appreciate the part
participation here from your folks and
now I would like to welcome Mark campen
who has joined us for taking us through
this career industry Master Class here
uh so mark first of all would like to
thank you for taking the time out for
this interesting session we haveed
signed up today and problem and also
would like to welcome you once again and
uh we would love to know a little bit
about you before we
start okay hello everybody it is good to
see so many people um over
130 uh attending this webinar could see
that there is a big contingent from
Africa uh even good to see that there is
somebody from Amsterdam which is my home
country um for your information I am
markk I actually have more than 40-year
experience nobody has beaten me in that
number um 40 years experience in
marketing digital marketing
technology and um I am on the faculty of
Simply learn I have been there for a
number of years and I am one of the uh
the instructors for the pgdm which is
the um postgraduate digital marketing
program that we will be talking about
today I'm terribly excited to have the
opportunity to get you all on board yes
so don't hesitate and um jump on the
train because it can ex it can change
your career drastically and there's lots
and lots of new things coming towards us
on the digital marketing landscape
naming a tool like jet GPT which is the
biggest change I have seen in my
Corporate Care career so and all of that
will be covered in the the pgdm program
so that's it for me and um I'll get back
to you shortly in the explanation of the
program uh thank you so much Mark uh for
the introduction and uh yes it's pretty
interesting I think we'll be covering
the program as well uh along with let's
start with talking about the careers in
digital marketing in
2024 so uh as we can see uh basically
unleashing digital marketing
power in the 2024 economy let's talk
about that how exactly it will be
changing here are um so here are three
key areas where we're going to see
massive change and a one of the biggest
areas that is being impacted by this is
the digital advertising and the online
consumer Behavior you may all have seen
that um your adverts on your Facebook or
your uh your YouTube after you visited a
website and then guess what half an hour
later you see an adver for that product
now that is retargeting and that is
something that Google has facilitated
for many many years that you can
retarget people and there's a lot of
privacy concerns in that now this is
going to end Google is going to stop
this and that is drastically changed in
the digital marketing scene and that
means that you need to look more
detailed into consumer Behavior it is
changing the digital advertising
opportunities and it is also really
accelerating a shift towards e-commerce
and online sales so three key areas that
we see happening in the digital
marketing um world as it were in the 20
24 economy and our program our training
program that we will be presenting to
you today is built around these new
digital marketing uh Powers as we can
call
them yeah uh totally agree with that
it's pretty interesting and as we have
talked about the digital marketing
economy here in 2024 let's talk about
the digital marketing skills uh that
will be opening up so many career paths
in 2024 as
well yeah what you see that a lot of
people nowadays they learn for jobs that
do not yet exist and you'll see the same
happening in the digital marketing world
yeah who two years ago would have
thought that one of the jobs for digital
marketing would be a prompt specialist
yeah somebody who writes prompts for
artificial intelligent tools like cat
GPT so there's lots of new areas
emerging besides the traditional areas
and there's many many exciting jobs
available in digital marketing depending
on your preference if you want to be
what I say a generalist or a specialist
yeah like a generalist would be a
digital marketing manager who knows
enough about everything in digital
marketing to um to run a digital
marketing program for a company
or you could be a specialist like search
engine optimization like website
marketing or an e-commerce manager or a
digital advertising manager or a social
media manager a Content marketing
specialist so lots of different jobs
that are available and the key decision
you need to ask yourself here do I want
to be a specialist or do I want to be a
generalist
agree to that uh I think being a
journalist or a specialist is one of the
things you need to ask yourself now we
have talked about the skills here uh
let's talk about U more about the skills
and the career options so you need to be
up to date uh in terms of skills for
digital marketing roles in 2024 and also
uh digital marketing as a career keeps
basically changing it keeps evolving you
need to basically learn new things you
cannot just uh sit on learn on a thing
and basically depend on that so what is
your comment on that
Mark yeah so here you see all the key
areas that are that we will be covering
um in our postgraduate digital marketing
program and these are the traditional
digital marketing specialisms that you
can focus on now if I would highlight
some of the hottest areas yes some of
the ones where you almost guaranteed to
get a job to me that would be get into
video marketing yeah video is key in
today's digital marketing landscape get
into um where did I see this web
analytics web analytics in my opinion is
one of the hottest and fastest growing
areas in digital marketing so if you
have any analytics Affinity then that
would certainly be an area where you
should look at and then there is the
whole fa area of content marketing
content marketing to me is the fuel of
your digital marketing or the um the
yeah the the engine that keeps your
digital marketing going and that content
marketing fuels your your social media
it fuels your email marketing it fuels
your website management it fuels your
video marketing and then last but not
least Ai and machine learning in
marketing artificial intelligence now
I've been in marketing for over 40 years
and what I have seen in the last year
with artificial intelligence and chat
GPT is literally the biggest change I
have experienced I've seen many things
I've seen the internet I've seen mobile
marketing I've seen office marketing you
name it all there but nothing has had
such an impact on the digital marketing
skill set as artificial intelligence and
that is something that we will um cover
extensively in the um in the training
the the postgraduate program that we
will be presenting to you
today uh those are a lot of skills
basically to learn digital marketing um
I must say but uh I while you were
speaking we do got few messages of folks
when you were talking about a journalist
or a specialist uh so I think we got few
messages that I will want to be a
journalist from heart and basically from
raki that me to as well so now that we
have talked about skills here we have
talked about what skills you need to up
to dat uh for a digital marketing role
in 2024 uh we are curious to know folks
like are you basically learning any of
these skills or planning to learn any of
these skills basically to be a digital
marketing expert uh in the coming year
so uh you can let us know on the chart
here as you can see a lot of the skills
here SEO content marketing web analytics
email marketing influence marketing uh
eii and machine learning marketing again
like that is the interesting one right
uh so are you guys learning any of these
skills you can let us know in the chat
here as we move on uh as we have covered
the skills here we have covered the
career options you can take up in
digital marketing so what exactly is
changing in the digital marketing space
for 2024 Mark yeah so what I just
mentioned yeah that Google is going to
stop the cookies tracking for companies
which means you can no longer Target
people who visit your website um with
advertising and that is going to have a
major impact on the digital marketing
space the reason why Google is doing
that is because of privacy
regulations you already see that
happening with Apple if you now download
an app on Apple iOS there will be a
question do you mind if we if this this
app provider tracks you with advertising
or um or not and these regulations for
instance have cost Facebook or meta a
tremendous amount of Revenue and um
because people the advertising has
become less um less attractive for um
for businesses so that is one big area
of change
uh there's also the aid driven
personalization what I just talked about
yeah like the chat GPT and the content
creation through artificial intelligence
is going to have a big impact in the
digital marketing space And Then There
are two areas which is voice search is
an important one and the second one is
the augmented reality two very exciting
areas voice search basically doing
search through voice boxes um
or doing search through voice on your
mobile that is a um yeah so the keyboard
is going to be obsolete in a few years I
think because it will all be driven by
by voice sustainable marketing is of
course something that is happening as
well um but it's not the highest
priority I'd say it is the augmented
reality where you use your mobile phone
to create the camera of your mobile
phone to create a virtual overlay over a
scene for instance that means you can in
a shop you can wear the clothes that you
want to buy yeah through augmented
reality and and more developments like
this yeah so lots and lots of changes
that are coming up and that is exactly
what we're going to be talking about in
the um in the uh the pro postgraduate
program I see by the way lots of chat um
messages popping up what if I don't have
any experience yeah then will I be able
to learn all this and of course that is
one of the reasons why you should be do
joining this program because in this
program you'll be able to learn
everything about all these topics and if
you then want to become a specialist you
can zoom in on any particular topic um
that that has that has your interest
like for instance D analytics or uh
video
marketing uh also Mark Hart EVN has
asked in the Q&A box I think you were
speaking about augmented reality AR
please explain ER I think a little bit
more in terms of advertising I think is
what his question is his I'm sorry I
couldn't make out from the name sorry
can you repeat it uh har has asked that
please explain explain a the augmented
reality uh basically which we're talking
about in advertising in the Q&A
box okay so if that was say question of
course what you can now do um with the
augmented reality you can really make an
immersive experience for your advertise
for your products through augmented
reality where people can actually
virtually use your product or virtually
see how the product would work in a real
time environment example I can go to the
um you all know Ikea the company yeah
they have an app called places I think
it is and you can select a table or a
chair or a bed from the the catalog and
then you can place that table in your
living room through augmented reality so
if that can be brought into the
advertising world that can really
personalize the experience the
advertising experience for um for the
users I hope I hope that uh gives you
some kind of explanation heart uh please
do let it let me know on the chat or in
the Q&A box if you have any followup
questions uh and as we move on uh we
have talked about the skills here we
have talked about uh the career paths
you can take up IND digital marketing in
2024 and we also talked about what
exactly is changing in the digital
marketing landscape here be talking more
about what exactly the part University
program covers uh and uh but before that
we would love to know what is the
biggest challenge you're facing uh when
it comes to becoming a digital marketing
expert so you can see a quick uh poll
which is launched uh where we would like
to understand what's stopping you from
becoming a digital marketing expert uh
where you can see four quick options
here so this one is a multiple choice Po
and you can s multiple options because
there can be multiple concerns uh for
making basically taking up a digital
marketing career right or becoming an
expert which you might be facing also uh
the four quick options I'll just read it
out for you uh as folks are basically
sharing their responses on the all here
I see the first one I can't find a
program with a fully comprehensive
curriculum uh second one I don't have
the Practical exposure I need to become
job ready third one I find it difficult
to learn from pre-recorded videos and uh
the last one my worksh won't allow me
enough time for learning so uh these are
the four options which you can see on
this poort uh we would where we would
love to understand what is the biggest
challenge you're facing but in case this
uh poll does not cover your responses
you can let us know on the chat or in
the Q&A box
uh I see a few Elm have also joined us
that's interesting uh I can see weni has
joined us I am a part of the program
hence not responding to the poll uh so
already in the words of becoming a
digital marketing expert so that's great
but uh Wy please uh that is a name I can
make out from your email ID please do
let me know if I'm seeing a wrong name
here uh but yeah please do let us know
if you uh now it's interesting that
youve already joined the course but I'm
pretty sure as LM while you basically
pursuing uh to become a digital
marketing expert uh so we would love to
know what kind of questions you might
have uh in general like while you're
taking of this program uh basically any
anything uh in related to a career U you
would want to take it can be becoming a
journalist or a specialist you anything
any questions you might have please V
cut do let us know yeah got your name so
yeah please do let us know in the Q&A
box and also folks uh while you're sping
the chat here uh we actually might be
missing your questions because you can
see the chart is so active that
uh we won't be able to find your
questions here and I would love to uh
you know get your all your queries
answered and addressed by Mark here uh
so please do let us know in the Q&A box
and I'll make sure that we addressed all
of your queries here so uh yes we are
getting a lot of questions in the Q&A
box as well uh and uh this poll
basically I see most of the folks have
already responded so that's great so I
think I'll just give five seconds more
for the poll here and uh I'll just
quickly end the poll in 5 seconds so
last 5 Seconds 5 4 3 2 1 let me quickly
end the poll and also share the results
with you let's see what is the biggest
challenge you're facing when it comes to
taking up a career in digital
marketing so as we can see that 63% of
the folks have voted for I wouldn't get
the Practical exposure I need to become
job ready and 34% of the folks have
voted for I can't find a program with
the fully comprehensive curriculum and
23% of the folks have voted for my work
schedule won't allow me enough time for
Learning and uh 18% of the FKS I voted
for I find it difficult to learn from
prerecorded videos so I think uh I think
we totally understand what are the
challenges you're facing and thank you
so much for sharing that with us now let
me introduce you to the P University's
postgraduate program in digital
marketing uh so the program basically
comes with the comprehensive curriculum
and an industry online learning path uh
here you get access to integrated case
studies and Hands-On projects for
practical experience online live virtual
classrooms with peer and instructor
interaction not just a pre-recorded
video which you need to watch and also
the program is co-created with meta
blueprint and also the content provided
here is Harvard Business publishing
education so the program duration for
this one is eight months and uh this
basically you can basically complete it
by just giving five to 10 hour per week
uh keeping in mind that you actually
might be a working professional or you
might be doing this your on the side as
well uh so this program basically uh
makes it very flexible uh in terms of
completing the program with just giving
five to 10 hours per week and U
depending on uh you know how your life
stand and schedule is as well so here as
we move on what exactly are you getting
uh from this program so you get a
post-graduate certificate uh from per
University as you can see on the screen
uh in digital marketing and uh also you
get Hands-On projects Capstone projects
which will be talking about more in the
upcoming slides and master classes EMAs
with puru and meta and also a Purdue
alumni association membership so that's
interesting because you get to be a part
of pni uh which will will'll be talking
more about the P University Advantage
here so what exactly having a Purdue uh
basically University on your resume of
portfolios what changes exactly so P
here uh is basically a 150 year old
University here established by a land
grant from the state of India
and it basically consistently tops in
one of the top university Public
University us universities and also has
produced Nobel Prize wi us so having a
per University on your CV is basically a
prestigious accomplishment recognized
worldwide uh for folks basically uh
trying to uh get that Academia or uh you
know University on your portfolio I
think this is like the best Advantage
you can take up in terms of digital
marketing because it comes with a meta
Advantage as well so the meta Advantage
here being The Meta blueprint
and where you can basically get access
to exclusive ask me session anything
sessions by meta and master classes by
meta experts industry recognized meta
blueprint certification exam preper
voucher as well which you can utilize it
while you're taking off this program uh
also the job assess Services we provide
from zip uh this is for India and us
only I'll be sharing the link of the
program where you can check out because
I saw folks have joined from different
different countries as well so you can
check out for your own country as well
so here for basically in Partnerships
with IM jobs we have partnered with IM
jobs for India and talent Inc for us uh
where you get resume building assistance
career monitoring mentoring and
interview prep sessions via webinars and
career phase as well so uh I think
someone asked me about the eligibility
for this program here so uh basically
there are few eligibility criterias
which you need to follow and B sites as
well uh you basically can be from a
marketing or non Market non- marketing
background and you need to have a
bachelor's degree in any discipline and
you need to have at least two years of
work experience that is required to join
this program so before we move ahead uh
if you have any questions about the
program in general uh please do let us
know on in the Q&A box we'll see if we
can take up few questions here uh
meanwhile I just quickly browse through
the questions here uh in the Q&A box if
you have any questions about the program
in general if you have any questions
about digital marketing career in
general if you're trying to transition
from a different uh career here uh you
can let us know in the Q&A box and we'll
be answering those uh questions
here okay let me just I'm quickly
browsing uh few uh questions here uh
which uh I think we can take up because
we've gotten plenty of questions uh so
we'll just take a few questions here as
promised shall I quickly run through a
few questions sure sure please Mara
there are a lot of questions okay
yeah yeah so um how do I get employed
and other companies that I can seek for
employment yeah so that's one question
how do I get a job in digital marketing
now um of course you saw on the previous
slide there's lots of help that you can
get through the program but also there
are lots of Hidden Treasures in digital
and social media to find jobs and one of
the best tips I can give to you if you
are searching for a job search on
Twitter or X search on Instagram search
on Tik Tok um for the people that are
not based in India and just add the
hashtag job or uh jobs or digital
marketing jobs or hash SEO yes so search
for SEO manager hashtag jobs or social
media manager or social media intern
hasht jobs and that will open a whole
world of job opportunities for you in
your your area so that is one question
what are the tools or coding languages
covered well we're not going to cover
coding yeah because coding is not really
required anymore in digital marketing
there are so many tools now that will
help you develop websites and develop
additional functionalities and don't
worry you are going to be bombarded with
tools in the program I'm a bit of a tool
geek yeah if I can find new tools that
will help me in digital marketing I will
always share those with my students I
think uh talking about tools here Mark I
think we basically uh can take them
through uh the how basically this
program you know builds their digital
marketing skills step by step so I think
also that we anyways we're going to
cover that so thank you so much for that
question picking up that question yeah
yeah so um important keys to remember
about SEO um keyword research link build
building um on page optimization off-
page optimization think about those are
there opportunities for Hands-On
projects or real world applications that
is what I like about this program folks
is that this program is loaded with
handson projects that you can work on
and that you can use as a as a proof of
evidence to prospective employers that
you have the experience um in digital
marketing that they
require um I'm a journalist and just
began transitioning into digital
marketing where do I start uh start from
the beginning yeah and since you are a
journalist start focusing on content
creation content marketing could
potentially be one of the areas that you
could work on um cookies will be
adjusted in the future will this affect
the pixel tracking yes that is exactly
what this will affect and catlo so how
do we prepare for the change in digital
marketing if augmented reality and
artificial intelligence comes up will I
have a job and I said at the very
beginning you will be studying for jobs
that do no long that do not yet exist
yeah so be prepared the jobs will be
there in digital marketing in the end it
comes down to people all those tools
like Ai and they will just make your
life a little easier a job role of a
generalist as a generalist you will
probably be working for a company as a
digital marketing expert if you're a
specialist you may be an SEO manager at
a very large company in a digital
marketing team or you may work for a
digital marketing
agency so um what other questions
quickly almost done you mentioned
cookies being stopped by Google what is
the implication is digital marketing
still going to be relevant actually yes
and it's going to be much more exciting
because you have to focus more on the C
customer and that is what marketing is
all about yep so that's was a good
question um how does data analytics Ai
and AR at Value to digital marketing AI
digital and particularly digital
analytics proves the success of what
you're doing or proves that it not
doesn't work and how you need to change
so analytics how can you improve things
if you can't measure it so that is the
uh one of the essence of digital
marketing
so what other question digital marketing
Alum please tell the job ofd I think
that's the most questions that I um that
I came across here so that's yeah Rasha
back to you uh thank you so much Mark
for taking a few questions here uh
during the session I think uh folks uh
we have taken a lot of these questions
but uh I think we have time so we can
you can let us know if you have any
questions more about the program or
digital marketing career General we'll
take more questions in some time now
let's talk about how this program
prepares you so I think Mark basically
gave you a little bit just of you know
how basically uh this program prepares
you but we'll be talking more about in
detail here uh so uh I think before we
uh go into the details here of the
program how exactly It prepares you I
think let's get them a glimpse of the
life tour of the learning environment
Park of the here okay let me share my
screen okay you need to stop sharing
Russia then I can share
okay share no yeah you should be able to
share now yeah yeah there we go uh it's
this
one okay so can I get a quick yes
confirmation in the chat that you can
see my screen with simply learn study
Central then I know that um people can
see what I'm doing excellent so here you
see this is the learning portal that you
will get access to when you sign up for
the uh the postgraduate program and here
you see the entrance to the postgraduate
program go to the program click on that
and this takes you to all the learning
elements and all the sessions so there
is an induction session there is
creating your own website is course
course one course two is the digital
marketing landscape behavioral marketing
here is course four that is search
engine optimization I'm running a um a
uh Cort at the moment and we've just
finished this uh module yes so let's
click on one so that we've just finished
the one the search engine optimization
what you see here there is the self
learning there are the live classes
there's the assessment which is the task
that you need to do to get your
certificate for this particular session
and then there is the um the
downloadable content that you can that
you can get so let's go to the self
learning yeah you see in the self
learning there's a whole range of of
videos yeah that you can go through let
me just clear that
here stop that just clearing my screen a
bit Yeah so here you see all the videos
that you can go through for so you have
a complete video based
selflearning program that you can go
through and part of that self-learning
program is that you have cheat sheets
that you have the access to the slides
that I will be using in the live classes
and that you get also access to some
premium digital marketing tools that you
can use to help you in your assignment
and then here you see the live classes
and you see the schedule for the classes
and that's where you will go when and
you are attending going to attend the
live class you go to this module live
classes and then you click on the
session yeah and then you will attend
that that session and that will be
registered for completion and this is
also where you can download the
recordings of the session in case you
have missed any um any any uh any
sessions yeah so that is basically in a
nutshell how we work with this there is
also a community section where you can
engage with other students and where
that we use for for q&as so very high
level overview of the learning portal
and um back to
youa uh sure Mark uh thank you so much
for taking us to the learning
environment of part University's post
program digital marketing uh so we
basically covered how you can uh
basically manage a curriculum and a live
virtual classroom tour here uh and here
as we move on we'll be talking about how
how this program builds your digital
marketing skills step by step so uh Mark
can you take us through these steps here
I think you talked a little bit about it
in
the yeah we talked about it a little bit
just quickly one question please asite
the live classes on the LMS are they
practically on how to go about digital
marketing so the live classes is not
going to are not going to repeat all the
slides yeah this is not Death by
PowerPoint so in the live classes I am
going to add my sort of cherries on the
pie yeah so it's very difficult because
CH the things change so fast in digital
marketing yeah so the slides if they are
from yesterday yeah they'll be outdated
today that's how fast it goes so I'll
make sure that I share with you the
latest and greatest so your knowledge is
up to dat to today and even to tomorrow
so it will be giving you an an update of
the status quickly go through the
program but also share lots of tools
tips and tricks templates cheat sheets
and what have you so it's very important
that you attend those live classes
because they will make your content come
to life all right so then how does the
program build your DM skills so it's
basically starts at the basis with um
the first one important one is the
website creation yeah it is my
recommendation to all the students make
sure that you have a website your own
website when you attend when you go
through this program because then you
can learn all the things that you um
that you sort of that you've learned put
them straight into practice on your own
website so in this first module I'm
going to show you how to create your own
website you may already have a website
you may want a website as your personal
um your personal presentation and what
have you we're looking at digital
marketing landscape and behavior
Marketing in general aspect and then
we're going into the nitty-gritty we'll
look at search engine optimization we'll
look at search engine marketing which is
basically online advertising and we'll
look at Social Media Marketing three key
areas that
drive digital marketing and drive
traffic to your website we're I'm going
to look are there any other areas that
you can exploit to drive more traffic to
your website and yes those are email
marketing mobile marketing and content
strategy we're then looking at
strategies yeah it's great to learn all
this but if you haven't got strategies
in place yeah then um yeah then it's
going to it's not really going to work
for you and we're also looking at
analytics and return on investment and
we're looking at Google analytics we'll
look at how to measure return on
investment how do you evaluate your
campaigns and then we'll look at the
future artificial intelligence now there
is AI is coming throughout the whole
program and I'll be sharing with you all
the latest and greatest tools when it
comes to um Ai and there's a lot more
than just chat GPT and then finally
there is the digital marketing Capstone
project which is your Flagship Flagship
project this is if particularly if you
haven't got experience
this is your opportunity to build your
digital marketing portfolio that you can
present in um to prospective employers
that you can say hey although I have not
done it in real time this is how I would
do it yeah when it comes to um putting a
project together for your for the
company or for the
customer all right press yeah uh thank
you Mark uh I think uh I think Susan has
also asked about uh if you can take uh
them through the them through a
practically uh you know detail of
practical challenges and basically how
exactly uh what happens in this program
how exactly the skills are built uh so I
think that answers your questions suzan
please do let us know also let's talk
about the ere as well as you can see the
digital marketing meta class for digital
marketing masterclass brand management
Advanced email marketing Advanced
content marketing Advanced mobile
marketing are the electives which you
can take up in the program uh they
basically come as optional uh and I also
a part of the program so you don't have
to pay anything extra for that it is up
to you if you want to take up uh these
electives also moving on the tools and
platforms you be learning in this
program as well so uh I think Mark as
you can see that a lot of folks have who
have joined come from a different
industry or a similar industry uh what
would you suggest folks to maybe start
with is something we can start about the
tools and platforms because there are so
many tools and platforms going to this
program uh we'll try to Maybe cover as
few as possible and you know um we can
share a explanation to them which will
give them an idea what exactly are these
tools which we are covering in the
program yeah so there's obviously the
tools that you need to run digital
marketing and those are tools like
Google analytics like if I want to
advertise on Google there's Google ads
if I want to advertise on Facebook there
is Facebook ads yeah there is um Sam
Rush is a tool for digital marketing um
tracking for SEO for Content management
and you have it so yes so there is a
split in the tools by the providers like
Google Facebook YouTube ping and
Linkedin and you name it yeah that you
need to run the um the advertising for
instance or the social media but then
there is a whole array of tools and
we're talking about thousands and
thousands of tools and I'll show you a
slide in the program if you join the
program yeah that will help you with all
those little things like doing keyword
research like doing link building for
your SEO like
making social media posts Graphics yeah
text uh tools that to that write for you
and what have you and that's I will be
showing a lot of free tools that um you
will that you can use because a lot of
the mainstream tools you pay for it and
I am since I'm Dutch I don't like to
spend money I'm quite Frugal so I'll be
sharing a lot of free tools with you
that allow you to do a lot of the same
things that you can do uh with the
expensive tools as
well uh thank you so much for taking us
to the tools and platforms here uh we
about the projects here as well which
you could get to work on on through this
program uh for someone who does not have
any experience with marketing these
projects definitely help you uh
basically showcasing your uh basically
your work experience real work
experience to your future uh you know
workplace so here Air France marketing
managing online reviews and advisor EO
strenting the brand uh with marketing
Yahoo pricing search Internet
advertising and many more such uh
basically projects which you can cover
in this program uh and also let's talk
about the Capstone project here so the
Capstone project here basically is
something which is built in a way that
mimics real life business scenarios for
True experience uh this is something for
folks who basically have again no
digital marketing experience or very
little uh this definitely will help you
showcase your experience uh to your
future emplo here so mark would like to
know I think the audience would love to
know here as well that how does having a
Capstone project uh you know on your
portfolio when you have no experience in
the marketing or very less comparatively
does help with showing that experience
because I think we have gotten few
queries that you know I don't have any
work experience but I have learned
marketing like how do I get it off yeah
well that's um you know when you have a
um uh when you are in a prospective job
situation and you have an interview if
in digital marketing if you can't show a
website that you have worked on if you
can't show a portfolio of digital
marketing projects that you've worked on
then it's very difficult to compete
against the people that can do that yeah
whether that experience is real time or
whether that experience is from the
classroom yeah and that is what this
program the PG the the postgraduate
program with the Capstone project helps
you in addressing so during the program
you will work on your own website yep
and that is um where you can practice
all the things you've learned like
search engine optimization like content
marketing like social media and um with
a Capstone project you actually can put
all the things that you've learned in
theory as it were you can put it into a
practical project that you are going to
schedule the entire digital marketing
for yeah and to me this is the um
the if if you're running the program and
thinking about the Capstone project as a
little side thing then you're missing
the point the Capstone project in my
opinion is probably the most important
part of the whole program where you
capture your learnings into a realtime
project that you can show to your pro
prospective
employer uh totally agree with that Mark
I think I think uh this is just I'm
asking for it because I've seen it I
think we've SE seen it in a previous
webinar as well your your website as
well I you talked about you need to have
a a good working portfolio website uh
would you would you be comfortable
showing us your website uh because yes
of course yeah yeah happy to show that
I'm pretty sure an audience can learn a
thing from you know to that as well yeah
simple simple website I'll show you
which is my personal sort of
portfolio and this is a simple Works
WordPress
website yeah it's just my name and that
turns into a website and here it is yeah
so digital Navigator this and this is
not a lot of work to make a website like
this yeah where you have your
presentation you have your about me your
resume your portfolio we not able to see
the website oh sorry sorry sorry sorry
yeah I need
share new share here we go
share yeah so here you see can you see
my website
now yeah show J in the chat okay yes so
you see my yes yes it site yeah so here
you see my personal portfolio website on
my name mark.com yep and this is not a
lot of work to to make on on WordPress
yeah where you have your about me your
resume your portfolio your blog and you
can make this as advanced as you want if
you open your about
me yeah it just gives you stuff about
what you do and and how you do it it
gives you stuff about your experience
you can make it a bit more um a bit
slightly bigger yeah I've uh I've
started a podcast yep so that is my
these are my blog posts so now if you
have a website like this coming out of
the PG program the postgraduate program
can you imagine the impact that will
make on the the pro your future employer
but of course it means that you need to
put the effort in to learn about this
and the effort to actually make a
website like this but that's where you
will be guided during the program to
come out with it like in with your own
personal folio website or you could have
your customer's website you may already
have a website for your own product or
your own um your own club or
Association and then you can use that
website to implement all the learnings
from the
program uh that's a very cool website uh
please let us know let us know folks
like how did you like the website as
well and I think they want a link on the
chat here as well if you can share that
that'll be great for them to refer to
yeah I think yeah we can see folks have
already asked asked ask me about it uh
let me quickly share back my screen uh I
hope you folks like the tour of marks
website as well as I told you it was an
interesting one so also the caption
projects which we cover here uh you can
see which the basically the projects you
can choose from in this program online
appil store online for Marketplace
online gadget shop online retail store
mobile app design platform uh being
basically all these five projects you
can choose from for project we have also
have global leaders as program advisers
Jin Shuli uh Brad gats Matt Bailey who
basically make sure that simply learn is
delivering asper standards uh of P
University when it comes to this proing
marketing course so uh let's talk about
the past Learners and their success as
well here the learner profiles
previously have consisted of Learners
from excellent organizations and diverse
Industries uh they come from Industries
like IT bfsi consulting others and
companies also they come from Amazon
Microsoft Del ble vone LinkedIn uh Wells
Faro being a very few of them and many
more uh we talk about the success
stories here we talk about maril here
who basically uh says that the
instructor was taru and has explained
digital marketing depth uh basically it
was very exciting for her and uh to be
able to attend the interactive classes
and also that basically she can take it
from anywhere uh here says that he
basically was awarded with job as a
marketing manager from one of Jamaica's
leading advertising agency uh this
certification was a game changer
basically for him and allowed him to
start his own company as well and scale
up his business uh K here as you can see
uh basically says that she's been with
simply learn uh for three years focusing
on digital marketing courses and the
courses have basically uh helped her uh
basically with a very well structured
delivery and with with best inass as
experts here uh girisha says that the
base of his learning uh was the
marketing principles from this course
which basically helped him achieve the
growth hacking approaches that basically
he applies today and he says that he'll
be coming back to along with his team as
well to get uh get them more
knowledgeable on a specific set of
coures so uh these are few of the
success stories which you can see here
but there are many more I'll be sharing
the link TOS program as well so we have
talked about the skills here we have
talked about the career paths we have
talked about what exactly is changing in
digital marketing space in 2024 and
Beyond we have talked about P
universities program how basically It
prepares you for the future here uh with
a lot of things you can learn which is
upcoming in the space and uh also we
have talked about the projects the
caption projects and the industry
projects which you can add in case you
don't have any experience in the
marketing or very little experience in
the marketing which you can showcase
your future employees where uh they
basically they require a job experience
here so a lot of things much more tools
platforms are cover CED in this program
and we have talked about how this
program basically builds your marketing
skill step by step so we would love to
know your interest are you interested in
enrolling theic program in digital
marketing and by University and also
let's not forget the bonus offer here
for attending the uh program here so you
be getting a bonus offer as well which
you can Avail as well uh throughout the
year because we have upcoming set of
cohort which you can basically take up
in this program so uh you can see a
quick poll on your screen here which
basically says uh would you like to in
rooll in the program of digital
marketing uh by P University the
postgraduate program so uh for folks uh
who are interested can share with us in
the poll yes and you can basically Avail
the bonus offer through this poll as
well so please do that uh meanwhile I
see the uh Q&A box is blowing up
completely from the last time we took it
so I think we have few minutes um where
we can take up maybe few questions or
maybe maybe Mark you can uh just browse
through it and if you see we have time
right now as folks are sharing responses
for the poll here and take up few
questions uh if you see uh questions
here which are relevant as well okay so
yeah I go backwards from the end so our
website free of charge uh yes there are
tools that allow you to make a free
website and I'll be sharing those tools
with you in the program as well from
your experience how can one go into
marketing analytics what combination of
courses do you need well the most
important part where you start is with
Google Analytics
and then get a good understanding of all
the analytics aspects of um the uh the
social media platforms like Facebook and
like like LinkedIn so get as much
knowledge of all the digital analytics
aspects of the um the digital marketing
landscape and so a lot of that will be
covered Susan in the the program but
then I would go into some specialist
courses as well go into an in-depth
Google Analytics program yeah and
there's lots of programs available um as
well
so I mean Susan from the learning
management system is it showing the
practicality on what to do showing us
how to use the tools so this is not in
learning the definition of terms yeah in
the um the live classes where actually
you have the opportunity to use a number
of tools in the learning the live
classes you'll be developing your own
Google ads advertising campaign yeah
I'll let you create your own video that
you will use for a video ad so very
handsome practical
sessions
so there's another practicality
question more about Google analytics and
well if I start on Google analytics I'll
be talking still tomorrow so it's um
Google analytics has just gone through a
major new upgrades in Google analytics 4
so do a search in ga4 or Google
analytics 4 and start familiarizing
yourself with this if I plan to open our
own agency how can we find clients now
good point that you bring that up shamin
Muhammad um what you see is a lot of
people who attend these classes they are
actually going to start their own agency
they're actually going to start their
own freelance business
and between you and me is something that
I would certainly consider because there
is a lot of potential it's how I started
yeah with my own business I started
locally I started to build a website for
a friend and I did it for free I asked
him hey can I uh use you as a reference
I started to do some training and that
slowly developed to um working globally
on digital marketing for many different
businesses so great if if you are going
to use this to start your own businesses
now how do we find new clients um well
that is a long story um so I mean and it
is actually something we will be
covering in the program as well so there
is um some of the answers to
questions and that is I think thank you
so much for taking up a few questions as
folks were sharing responses for the
poll here for the enrollment uh so great
news that we have gotten lot of interest
towards enrollment so let me quickly
take them through the enrollment steps
here uh as we have uh some time left for
the webinar by a few minutes so folks I
think someone asked about the fee here
as well so uh I'll be sharing the link
for other countries here but for the fee
uh for the program here for us
candidates is
$3,000 USD dollar and for Indian
candidates it is 1 lakh
1,999 including GST uh so uh for folks
joining from uh different uh BC Bally
countries here I'm sharing the I will be
sharing the link towards the program
here and also in case you require any
assistance you can always reach out to
us at ask us at simple.net I'm sharing
that email ID on the link here as well
so you need to follow three simple easy
steps basically to enroll into the
program you need to submit an
application to us at
ask.net your application will reviewed
based on the eligibility and prequisites
I have told you about I've showed you
about the program and based on that
simply learned Consultants will be
reaching out to you with an admissions
offer which basically you can Avail with
the both business offer after showing
interest towards the Endor in this
program also uh we have the upcoming
classes which are starting on January
2th next year 2024 and the interactive
classes the interaction classes
basically be starting from JN 4th here
uh here and folks U I'm pretty sure like
you might have questions about okay I'm
not sure when to start so I'm not sure
exactly when do I start or I want to
start immediately so for that this is a
quick poll which I'm launching here to
understand how soon do you plan to
enroll this program uh so you can see
four we options here uh I would really
encourage for a lot of the folks who
have shared interest in enrollment into
the part University digal marketing
program here uh to be please let us know
through this poll when do you plan to
enroll so you can see four quick options
here immediately within three months
within six months and more than six
months from now so this will give us an
understanding when exactly to reach out
to you and also basically you can Avail
the bonus offer through this so uh folks
who basically want to join the immediate
Cohan which is on January 20th I would
recommend to select with immediately and
folks who are still thinking about it
they are still planning about it and are
confused I would suggest to select any
of those three options I would say so
within three months within six months
within more than six months from now
which is the most suitable for you uh so
I think I'll just give five seconds more
for the poll here because uh a lot of
folks have shared basically interest in
enrollment and this is very important
for those folks to do let us know
basically when do you plan to enroll
and uh I see a question what about other
country students definitely I will be
sharing the link for you on the chat
here so you can check out uh basically
the fee uh and the upcoming cohard for
your own region here as well I hope you
have shared your interest in the
enrollment poll to Avail the bonus offer
so I'm sharing the link uh towards the
program here to check out for your own
country region uh Mohammad please uh
check out here the link to postgraduate
program in marketing by P University
here you can check out for your own
region here I hope that helps and also
for this poll I see folks have already
responded for the poll here so that's
great so let me quickly end the poll in
5 seconds so 5 4 3 2 1 let me quickly
end the poll thank you so much for
sharing that with us and as we have
taken a lot of questions so uh
throughout the session and even now so
uh we will maybe just check out if there
are any more questions but before that
please do let us know if you need
assistance in enrolling to the program
please do check this out uh this poll
here and also folks uh if you have any
questions about the program uh should
you require any further assistance uh
you can always mail us at ask us.net
I'll just quickly share that on the
chart once again if you have any more
questions about the program so your
Learning Journey is a priority and we
are here to support you every step of
the way so uh I'm just sharing the email
ID once again on the chat here so so you
can always reach out to there us there
in case you have any more questions
anyways uh once basically the learning
Consultants from will reaching out to
you they will be taking you on a much
more detailed walk through of the
program here so okay uh I see yes I need
please do put it on basically a response
on the poll as well so we might miss it
from the chat here so I think uh I think
we are towards the end of the program
here uh we try taking I think almost all
questions as possible uh so uh thank you
so much for your interesting questions
and actively participating uh in the
program here and also uh we will be
basically ending the session now because
we are towards the end of session and uh
before that I would love to thank markia
uh for your time and taking us to this
interesting Master Class here and
showing us your amazing website as well
and sharing that here as with the folks
here as well so I think uh we are
looking forward to see you uh in the
upcoming cohs of the P University
cohorts here but Mark would you like to
say something to the folks here before
we
position yes um thanks for uh for
inviting me um as you can see from my
enthusiasm I am very passionate about
this and um I can only close with the
one statement that you will find on my
website as well yeah that learning is so
important to develop yourself and my
personal mission is to inspire people to
always be learning because when you
learn you you develop when you learn you
grow and the beauty about digital
marketing there is so much to learn and
so much of those learnings even if it's
a little bit you can immediately turn
into opportunities so I hope to see all
of you in one of the uh the programs um
I wish you all the best good luck with
your with your career and your career
change and um hopefully we meet sometime
online soon
thank you once again Mark and we see a
lot of responses here please folks let
us know how did you like the session I
see a lot of uh uh like positive
comments coming in here so uh thank you
once again for being an amazing audience
here so uh and looking forward to see
you in upcoming calls with simp for
University program so I hope uh this
link of the program for folks who have
joined from different countries uh
helped you and please do check it out
and in case you have any questions you
can let us know on the email ID which
I've already shared with you I just
share it uh again here and also about
the postar surve which I told you in the
starting in case any of you have missed
so uh once they end the session you will
get a post webinar survey popup uh which
basically you can uh utilize in case you
have any feedback for us to make our
webinars better uh because these
webinars is basically for you you know
they should be better and better with
every webinar we do and we a lot of the
do a lot of these webinars here I've
shared those link of those web webinars
with master classes you can check out on
this link here and also basically uh we
will be ending the session also so thank
you once again thank you uh for being an
amazing audience and see you in the next
webinar thank you thank you
folks